and about paris to what you have already
been to paris in france in general you
have had contact with an ace of the
french no i have a
mentality
of a year
but
it takes a
is what is what do you believe  that the
French well I heard I heard it
said in general when I was in France
for example meeting Quebecers
it's not that they make fun of their
accent but you see I even wrote an
article on that  there are always conflicts or
not it involves nes understands
for example in Spanish there are
South American accents and the European accent and
the same thing for Portuguese and I
think it's a bit a bit roughly
the same thing in French it means
that sometimes the Québécois accent or
the French accent they are a little they
are quite different but if you will not have the
same language then have you ever
felt felt some kinds of footsteps
mockery but
that's what I wanted to know because
in fact knowing French people and
saying  nt always that for them the
Quebec accent is an accent there are some who
say that it's very pleasant there
are others who say that it's a little
weird but that's normal because
it's  always the story of accents it
always works like that when you
take it you hear a different accent
it's good it's different so isn't
used to it what do you think you
're getting used to hearing anyway
the french of france because there
is a television so to
understand this france
it must be said that what we learn
at school is really
french spelling during parized french
france and then therefore written french  in
quebec to even start thinking of
france if the french really passes and
then when he talks about mockery or
that kind of bad feeling yes yes that's
what that kind of feeling that I think
probably not take the skin all
the time  world that is going on at the moment
but there are several people who I
p  I find it only in Quebec
for example and several people who
think that the French accent are a
little happy with my time
and then a little bit
uncomfortable if a person who speaks
with an accent that is a little too polite between
I know  not where you are a bit
but anyway apart from that there
won't be any between quebec and france and
French-speaking countries so
pretty much in general I really like
finally
yes I am I completely agree
you go to italy for example i know that
the italians are quite popular in
france but the french are not
so popular for all of them in
italy and in that the french are
quite
surprised and astonished because they actually
call themselves a handsome  italy is
like us but in general when i
went to france because here there is a
feeling if it's not an anti
french feeling but you see all the things
we say generation after generation there
is always  this
there are meadows  judged from whom I came I
arrived I landed in France I
found a magnificent country and the people
were very nice good Parisians
we generally say without however I
don't think that at the base but there are some
who are of course a  not very haughty
but in general I found a very
very welcoming country and I think that speaking
their language is very important because
in France in fact we do not speak
much English he spoke French
directly with them it changes everything the
same thing  it goes for the Italians we
have the impression that the Italians are
very warm people it's true on the one
hand but if you don't speak their
language report it that you established with
the historian peels it's not  the same
relationship as if you spoke Italian and
that goes for all the countries stagnates and it's the
same thing so I think you have to
live in a country to see a year you
can't judge that the people who is he
that the  tourists arriving in your
country I think we should  inhabiting a
bridge and
the language helps a lot have inhabited it
and by lille ranging from the price
i wanted to ask you also the first
time i saw i don't know if you know
the movie the decline of the american empire
the first time i  I've seen them it's been
it's not it's been 15 years I thought that
it's because of my ignorance I was
a little surprised because I thought they
were killing me because I had never
heard never heard Quebecois so
just with age I thought it was
a little
French infiltrated very interesting made
a note another film also
do you know of other films very well known in
Quebec for example by the hope that
I  I saw a son called croesi
I don't know without a doubt I can
buy because I'm I'm interested
anyway
this film much more the artery walls
more agronomy
this film from 2005 there are many many
of Quebec films that will save theaters
every year, so the
Quebec industry scene  of Quebec films is
still very developed and since, which is
still a contrast with the
Canadian film industry in the rest of Canada,
so to which a lot a lot
of TV series films also I have a lot of
films are very popular so if you
want  I can give you I like this style
and then I can give it would be otherwise
it would be great so a comedy that
had been very popular it's called the
great seduction
begins to see in it a doctor who
allows himself on a small island because
supports Quebec then from time to
time need a doctor and then they have
to seduce a doctor so that the
dakar is invited in it was for him to
become their doctor so that's a
woman was already quite funny comedy
sporty boys it was very
popular in Quebec it's a
rock comedy and therefore a rock team and that's
how I listened to that which I trained in
but it was very very popular since
they made four films before  nt fatal
for his series against the bosses of the bosses
of the boys 3 he is beautiful he is beautiful this
case it is very popular
so leading the decline of the american empire
is a fact of the 80s
very popular crime comedy bamba k
c  is the second most popular film
of the decade very very popular
another firm the sequel to good cop bad
cop was already filled another
popular comedy and very
acclaimed and then otherwise i would say
elvis gratton
it's not for everyone c  he's a
new guy a little fat sylvain
dumons a little
I would say broken but it's very very
Quebecois a lot of patois a
lot of diana Quebecois who
excuse so it can be also
interesting to use the language
since the future launcher
of what
really far far too many to
add up but I recommend people
who are interested in watching
Quebec films to do a simple search
and I saw I remember that when
I saw crazy crazy cra  zy I don't know
invited in English there were
sometimes subtitles so when the because
in fact it was the film arrived in
France too but sometimes he uses
the expression it's very difficult to
understand even if it's  French
so I was wondering if there are
typical Québécois expressions
French game not getting it in fact he does
n't get it I remember that there was the
lumeau tank the tank stop the car launched
the car is what you say cars
by  example in quebec never the car
I
seize coal on
a tank
is what you disappear yes it's
my
jargon yesterday I read somewhere that the
Quebecois 25
and then the French of brakes are
about 13 so we  has a lot of marielle
so is it as it's more
complex as a system is what it is
it's easy faugoo for you
to imitate the French accent it's
easier than for the de to imitate the  Quebec accent
or
therefore
much easier than people
normals and france jamet
the québecois accent